nicolas vidal bonjour très heureuse de
vous retrouver en chair et en os sur ce
plateau vraiment ainsi pendant tout
cette aide entre un hall du magasin
alors en tout cas quelques mois de la
présidentielle les républicains ils sont
dans les starting blocks et quels sont
les rapports de force ah oui mais le
problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas assez de
starting blocks départ de la course et
qu'il ya trop de candidats pourront
couloirs trop étroit car les
républicains c'est devenu un peu l'armée
mexicaine de la politique française il y
à plus de 4 que le candidat ait autant
d'idées que de gagnants du loto mais
comme ils sont copains comme cochons
tous les candidats stone donné rendez
vous aux journées parlementaires à nîmes
le 8 et 9 septembre peuvent dernier pour
une très grosse bonbonne valérie
pécresse eric ciotti xavier bertrand
michel barnier et philippe juvin ils
étaient tous à accompagner des géo du
club bel air à savoir damien abad gérard
larcher christian jacob pour mettre
l'ambiance alors qu'eric zemmour vous le
savez est sanctionné par le csa sur ces
news et bien les républicains eux ils
parlent de plus en plus pour ne rien
dire et ce n'est pas demain que ce rsa
les pointent du doigt car il s'explique
cette kim fait républicain - on les
comprend et en prime il faut remonter
emmanuel macron et l'acception ils sont
absolument redoutable mais après la
bamboche du 8 et 9 septembre présidée
par le disc jockey christian jacob aux
platines parlementaire on va tenter ce
matin de comprendre qui chez les
républicains a le moins de chances du
pont neuf est que dis-je une grosse
doudoune pour l'hiver une grosse
doudoune ces circonstances alors nicolas
quel est le meilleur candidat pour
représenter la droite en avril 2022 ben
je me suis creusé la tête 1.2 le plus
clair possible ce matin et je n'ai donc
pas pris exemple sur christian jacob
dont je ne pourrais jamais égalé le
charisme et l'éloquence donc on va faire
un tour d'horizon rapide des trois
principaux prétendants à la fonction
suprême alors commençons par xavier
bertrand et par une déclaration faite
chez nos confrères de midi libre je cite
nous ne sommes pas obligés de ressemble
aux états unis où le fric fait tout
pendant les campagnes électorales alors
oui alors oui d'accord l'argent ne fait
pas tout certes mais les powerpoint
d'idées toutes prêtes et les barquettes
micro ondable conviction perdu eh bien
ça coûte un bras dans une agence de
communication peu sérieuse donc il va
falloir sérieusement réfléchir à la
stratégie de ségolène royal en 2007
rappelez-vous qui a démis en place un
bureau des idées bond poursuivi des
légendes va repasser un car c'est le
meilleur même rien d'avoir un truc à
dire surtout lorsque vos idées sont les
mêmes que celles vendues dans la
boutique d'à côté tenu par emmanuel
macron xavier bertrand c'est aussi un
plébiscite de 17% des inscrits dans les
hauts de france pour les régionales donc
lorsque l'intrépide aller bertrand 3 10
personnes habitudes ou à dunkerque - de
deux personnes ont voté pour lui mais
vous savez la fonction suprême c'est la
rencontre d'un homme et d'un peuple avec
une vision pour un destin commun bla bla
bla bla bla bla mais pour xavier
bertrand cette rencontre semble plutôt
serment de louche à la fin d'un loto du
troisième âge un dimanche après-midi
novembre mais il avait bertrand lui il
s'en moque car à dunkerque ils marquent
la tête valérie pécresse après avoir
enflammé la piste de danse à nîmes
pendant les journées parlementaires est
allé faire des mamours à fabien roussel
lors de la fête de l'humanité le 13
septembre dernier c'était tellement
mignons ils se sont même promis 1
écoutez de ce bart scott accord entre
bruxelles comme ça si ça se passe mal
pour valérie à la présidentielle elle
lui restera la cgt et la fête de l'huma
pour vendre des fanions c'est elle aussi
qui se considérait le dernier comme deux
tiers merkel un catcheur alors
spontanément j'essaie de voir ce que ça
donne mais c'est très difficile à
imaginer mais bon pour faire simple
dites-vous que valérie pécresse et
surtout 3/3 nacro compatible michel
barny alors lui c'est le monsieur de
droit commun et des convictions
politiques il faut se rappeler que
michel barnier a été entre autres deux
fois commissaire européen et négociateur
en chef du break si des versions gign
dont bruxelles c'est son dada sa
patience son sacerdoce en hygiène de vie
mais la mission il a décidé de casser
les codes il a décidé de un grand
coup de patin dans la fourmilière
européiste et ça y est il a mis en pl
est où les eurobéats en parlant de
souveraineté juridique de la france
alors que tellement bonne nuit
l'apprenti ce coup de l'union européenne
s'indigne on le comprend mais au sein
des républicains la pilule ne passe pas
du tout et michel n'est pas loin du tout
du test pcr forcé pour détecter chez lui
onemain le virus ou venise bien sûr on
sourit beaucoup nicolas mais ce que les
républicains vont parvenir à trouver un
candidat unique pour la présidentielle
un bain vous l'avez compris c'est la
chienlit comme exigé radebeul chesnais
l'air le maréchal la défaite christian
jacob a évoqué deux formules cette
semaine pour désigner le pilote de la
machine à perdre alors ce n'était pas
très clair mais ça pourrait de la
fameuse primaires ouvertes ou semi
ouverte on sait pas à tous où le congrès
des militants avec son flanc marseillais
des tables en plastique mais peut-être
que la solution chers amis il peut venir
jeune aurélien pradié qui a déclaré
récemment je cite pour gagner la droite
doit s'adresser aux français fait en
même temps si les républicains ont
décidé de parler aux belges des
espagnols ça va se compliquer
sérieusement mais dans la précipitation
vous savez on n'est jamais à l'abri de
faire des choses totalement insensé mais
les républicains peuvent compter sur
leur pointure comme damien abad qui
rappelle qu'il faut augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat des français ou christian jacob
qui ne manque jamais eu depuis 20 mois
la droite c'est totalement reconstruites
ou encore depuis deux ans la droite
remporte victoire sur victoire et comme
le disait coluche d'ailleurs devenu très
à la mode chez les manifestants qui
passe à me taire je cite le plus dur
pour les hommes politiques c'est d'avoir
un mémoire qu'il faut pour se souvenir
de ce qu'il ne faut pas dire merci
nicolas on n'est pas plus avancé un
merci en tout cas de second décryptage
c'était l'édito politique de l'alma
tidal mai à londres ce qui t'est nicolas
une réaction peut-être à cet échange
plutôt glace entre que xavier bertrand
emmanuel macron c'était avant-hier en
marge du discours de clôture du bureau
de la sécurité dans les hautes france
regardez
[Musique]
les républicains
et bien sourire de continuer à composer
[Musique]
forcément à court terme j'aurai
l'occasion demain
[Musique]
et voilà la phrase qui tue nicolas vidal
involontaire bah oui merci monsieur le
président au conseil général voilà
glaçant et condescendant emmanuel macron
3 et xavier bertrand à dire emmanuelle
bertrand vous voyez la puce mais c'est
les aviez bertrand bien entendu il est
extrêmement reconnaissant dans emmanuel
macron il le regard de sa hauteur il
avait bertrand essaye de prendre le
pouls redire le lead finalement
finalement oui c'est un bon soit
posséder bertrand qui essaie de
s'imposer en stature mais ça ne marche
pas du tout merci beaucoup nicolas on se
retrouve jeudi prochain bien évidemment
pour un nouvel édito